[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend die Debatte um die
silvesterkrawalle in Berlin und anderswo
treibt mittlerweile bizarre Blüten da
fordert der Berliner CDU-Chef die
Vornamen der mutmaßlichen Täter mit
deutscher Staatsangehörigkeit zu
erfahren wohl in der Erwartung dass sie
nicht Hans oder Karl lauten und die
bundesinnenministerin von der SPD denkt
beim Besuch der Neuköllner Feuerwache
darüber nach wie man die Waffengesetze
verschärfen könnte unsere Reporter
Christ hat Läpple hat in Neukölln
Polizisten und andere Menschen getroffen
die sich mehr über friedliche
Sternsinger wundern als über die dort
herrschende Gewalt
alle Jahre wieder Neukölln
330.000 Einwohner so viel wie Bonn 150
Nationen und stets für Überraschungen
gut an diesem Dreikönigstag ziehen
Sternsinger von der katholischen St
Christophorusgemeinde zum Rathaus Geld
sammeln für Bedürftige ein kleines
Zeichen der Hoffnung für Pater Lenz bei
dem die Probleme an die Kirchentür
klopfen
man muss ja ehrlich sagen Silvester es
gibt ja was weiß ich bvg-fahrer werden
Busfahrer werden attackiert oft oder
kolumbiadam Schwimmbad da draußen
Sicherheitsdienst und Einsatz oft damit
man da in Ruhe schwimmen kann also es
gibt schon soziale Herausforderungen und
Probleme auch das ist Neukölln am drei
königstag ausgebrannte Fahrzeuge auf der
Sonnenallee angezündet wurden sie am 2
Januar am Tag nach neuer
die Täter sind unbekannt eine Anwohnerin
ist entsetzt
ein
ich finde es ist nicht mehr normal alles
ja
gewalt gehört leider zum Alltag für
Polizisten selbst die silvesterattacken
auf Rettungskräfte überrascht sie nicht
mehr darüber offen reden will kaum
jemand ein Neuköllner zivilgefahren da
gibt Auskunft erkannt werden will er
nicht da ist kompletter Hass gegenüber
uns den Vertretern des Staates zu spüren
und täglich zu erleben und da ist eben
diese westernacht eigentlich nur das
i-Tüpfelchen gewesen
Karl-heinz Gärtner kann offen reden als
einer der wenigen Polizisten in Berlin
44 Jahre war er in den Straßen von
Neukölln im Einsatz 5000 Straftäter hat
er festgenommen drei Bücher im Ruhestand
geschrieben seine Bilanz nichts hat sich
verbessert im Gegenteil
wenn ich vorher recht aussagte dann
würde ich Teil seines vor Gericht als
Rassist beschimpft
Polizeiarbeit im multikulti-bezirk
Neukölln bedeutet eine ständige
Gratwanderung zwischen verschiedenen
Kulturen und Vorstellungen von Recht und
Ordnung Gärtner berichtet von
Parallelgesellschaften
dort auf dem Mittelstreifen gab es eine
Messerstecherei wir als Funkwagen
dorthin es waren ca 20 bis 30 Jahre
Menschen um den Verletzten darum
plötzlich kam also ein älterer Mann auf
mich zu äh gab mir eine Karte und sagt
guten Tag ich bin ja der Friedensrichter
es ist alles schon hier rede sie können
wir losfahren wenigstens die kleinen
Sternsinger können Erfolge vermelden
mehr als 100 € haben Sie gesammelt
Menschen in Not ja ja und zwar
Kinderrechten
vielen Dank auch das ist neu Köln
und aus Berlin ist uns jetzt fördermann
zugeschaltet unabhängige Beauftragte des
Bundes für Antidiskriminierung und
Autorin eines Buchs über Einwanderung
und Integration guten Abend Frau
ottermann guten Abend Frau gelenik
Deutschland diskutiert jetzt seit sechs
Tagen über die Silvesternacht in Berlin
was ist ihre Sichtweise wie ist es zu
der zu dieser gewaltentladung in
Neukölln gekommen
zunächst einmal ist es mir wichtig zu
sagen dass die Gewalt die ich auch
gesehen habe die wir beobachten konnten
mich schockiert hat und sehr betroffen
macht und ich hoffe und davon ausgehe
dass die Berliner Behörden den
Rechtsstaat konsequent durchsetzen und
die roten Linien ähm klar machen hier
wurden rote Linien überschritten und das
kann man so nicht akzeptieren
gleichzeitig muss ich sagen dass ich
gerade sehr irritiert bin über die
Debatte die wir führen statt darüber zu
reden dass es große Probleme offenbar
mit Jugend Gewalt gibt statt über
Sozialpolitik Städte Politik und so
weiter zu reden oder über Gewaltexzesse
reden wir eigentlich seit sechs Tagen
darüber ob man jetzt sagen darf wie
viele der täter:innen vor Ort ein
Migrationshintergrund hatten oder nicht
aber ist das irritierende an der Debatte
nicht auch dass es offenbar eine
Mehrheit von Angreifern gibt die Zweifel
los Männer mit Migrationshintergrund
sind und die sich mit unserem
Rechtsstaat überhaupt nicht
identifizieren die einfach sagen Bullen
klatschen ist für uns okay wie kann es
wie kann es zu so einer Situation kommen
tatsächlich wissen wir überhaupt nicht
ob es eine Mehrheit der Angreifer
deutschlandweit ist wir warten gerade
auf das Lagebild dass das
Innenministerium macht um mal zu gucken
was überall flächendeckend in
Deutschland passiert ist das was sie
sagen was wir wissen ist dass es in
Neukölln eine Mehrheit der Täter war das
darf ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht
verwundern wenn man sich auskennt weiß
man in Neukölln einem Stadtteil in
Berlin der sehr stark migrantisch
geprägt das sind über die Hälfte der
Kinder und Jugendlichen aus
Einwandererfamilien insofern sind sowohl
auf der Seite der Täter in als auch auf
der Seite der der Polizistinnen und der
Eingreifen wie sagt man ja hilfsgruppen
die vor Ort waren waren Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund das ist erstmal
ganz normal in Deutschland heutzutage
dann frage ich mal so ist es
diskriminierend in Deutschland zu sagen
wer die Täter sind und was ihr
Hintergrund ist und dass sie einen
Migrationshintergrund haben
also es wäre richtig entweder immer
Migrationshintergründe oder nicht
vorhandene Hintergründe zu sagen oder
eben nie punktuell sich jetzt raus zu
greifen bei dieser einen Gruppe da sagen
wir da sind aber viele Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund und bei anderen
Übergriffen z.B auf die Polizei wenn er
nicht gesagt wird das waren aber alles
weiße deutsche und die haben jetzt die
Polizei angegriffen dann ist da eben ein
Ungleichgewicht zumal es auch wichtig
ist viele haben jetzt gesagt man darf
nichts verschleiern dass kann man so
sehen definitiv aber dann muss man eben
auch sagen auch auf der Seite der
Betroffenen der Opfer waren viele
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund auch
auf der Seite der empörten übrigens es
sind Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
gerade genauso empört über das was sie
gesehen haben in den Nachrichten mit
Migrationshintergrund und wenn man das
mitsieht sozusagen dann gibt es ein
Gesamtbild das ist dann nicht
diskriminierend wenn man aber nur
punktuell bei Problemen auf MigrantInnen
und ihre Nachkommen zeigt dann
stigmatisiert man eine Gruppe die dazu
führt dass viele Menschen im Alltag
tatsächlich
öfter Benachteiligung erleben und sich
bei uns bei der
anti-diskriminierungsstelle des Bundes
melden und rassistische Diskriminierung
beklagen gut aber wir haben jetzt aus
Neukölln ein Bild von Tätern mit
offenbaren migrantischem Hintergrund was
muss jetzt passieren damit sich sowas
nicht
wiederholt damit wir nicht jetzt uns
aufregen und in einem Jahr
geschieht wieder genau dasselbe
also die Polizistinnen und Polizisten
mit denen ich privat gesprochen habe die
wünschen sich alle schon immer dass man
genauer hinguckt und tatsächlich eben
mehr Maßnahmen ergreift das geht dann
tatsächlich in eine Richtung das sind
kompliziertere Antworten als wir sie
derzeit auf dem Tisch liegen haben da
geht es dann um Städte und Sozialpolitik
also Stadtpolitik Jugend
Gewaltprävention etc tatsächlich muss da
einiges geschehen und auch gerade in so
Brennpunkt Gebieten wie z.B neu Köln in
Teilen eines ist es gibt auch schöne
Ecken in Neukölln aber es gibt natürlich
auch tatsächlich problematische Ecken
dort und da muss reingegangen werden das
ist keine Frage aber das hat eben nichts
mit Migrationshintergrund per se zu tun
dass das glaube ich ist ganz wichtig
dass wir im Moment merken wir führen
eine Debatte die Millionen von Menschen
in Deutschland vor den Kopf stößt und
die sie ratlos hinterlässt weil sie
einerseits sehen dass sie genauso im
kürzen wie alle anderen auch aber nur
genannt und gesehen werden wenn es um
die Täter geht bringt so einen Jugend
wie die Regierende Bürgermeisterin in
nächste Woche abhalten will etwas oder
das Waffenverbot was die Innenministerin
vorgeschlagen hat das kann mit
Sicherheit was bringen natürlich aber
wir müssen auch über Jugendgewalt und
Prävention reden also wenn wir bedenken
dass im in den letzten Monaten zum
Beispiel auf tiktok einer
Jugendplattform ein Hashtag namens The
purge getrennt hat bei dem es um
exzessive Gewaltausbrüche geht und das
wurde gefeiert drauf und runter von
Jugendlichen das sind Punkte wo wir auf
jeden Fall auch mit Forschenden
reingucken müssen und verstehen müssen
was passiert da wie kann es zu solchen
Gewaltausbrüchen kommen und ähm dagegen
müssen wir etwas tun keine Frage sagt
Werder Ackermann Beauftragte des Bundes
für Antidiskriminierung herzlichen Dank
für das Gespräch nach Berlin danke auch
Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir aus Termin
Gründen am Abend aufgezeichnet und im
heute-journal Update spricht Christopher
Wehrmann mit der Neuköllner
Integrationsbeauftragten Güner
das in Berlin Wahlkampf ist merkt man
natürlich auch an der Debatte über die
Silvesternacht die verpatzte Abstimmung
vom letzten Jahr wird in fünf Wochen
wiederholt eine Wahl auf die besonders
die FDP mit einer gewissen Nervosität
schaut das Trauma der vergeigten
niedersachsenwahl bei der die Liberalen
an der fünf Prozent-Hürde scheiterten
wirkt noch nach die FDP fühlt sich nur
mäßig wohl in der Ampelkoalition und die
Rolle allein als Bremserin rot-grüner
ampelprojekte zieht nicht wirklich bei
den Wäldern was also tun krawalliger
werden oder eigene Erfolge Stärke
hervorheben Britta Buchholz berichtet
vom drei königstreffen in Stuttgart zu
Beginn eines schicksalsjahres für die
FDP
Christian Lindner Ziel an diesem Tag ist
klar er will die Partei Seele streicheln
[Musik]
ein fröhliches Jahr das braucht die FDP
dringend viele Liberale hadern mit der
Ampel bevor Lindner seine Sicht
schildert geben klimaaktivisten aber ein
unerwünschtes Gastspiel
fest nimmt viel Kleber denn wenn ihr
hier klebt könnt ihr niemanden sonst
behindern
Tosen dabei Fall Lindner trifft den Nerv
bei den Anhängern auch inhaltlich er
wirkt für Fracking für eine längere
Nutzung von Atomkraft für
Steuersenkungen alle Sprengstoff für die
Ampel für einige eine Provokation für
ihn das Gebot der Stunde
FDP sollte keine Vorschläge unterbreiten
die zu den Grünen passen die FDP sollte
weiter Vorschläge unterbreiten die zur
Realität passen zur neuen Realität
gehört ein voller Saal nach zwei Jahren
ohne Publikum treffen sich die Liberalen
wieder in Präsenz und sie loben sich
eine Corona Impfpflicht verhindert zu
haben nun müsse noch mehr kommen ich
erwarte von unserem Gesundheitsminister
das jetzt eine neue Phase eingeleitet
wird die Zeit die Phase der staatlichen
Maßnahmen und Instrumente muss aus
meiner Sicht bald vorbei sein jetzt muss
die Phase der Eigenverantwortung
beginnen Druck zahlt sich aus meinen sie
auch die Panzerlieferungen verbuchen sie
als eigenen Erfolg nur der Wähler nicht
2022 brachte vier enttäuschende
Landtagswahlen 2023 bringt vier
bangenende Spitzenkandidaten als erstes
geht der Berliner ins Rennen und macht
sich selbst Mut nach dem wahlchaos in
der Hauptstadt
so viele Chancen eröffnet und die wollen
wir nutzen am 12.2 dieses Jahr in Berlin
um genau das zu machen was jetzt ansteht
die richtigen Punkte in Berlin
anzusprechen und dafür zu sorgen dass
Berlin wieder funktioniert manche wollen
aber noch mehr eine neue Strategie
maximale Abgrenzung gerade bei der
Energie die Frage ist wie kompensieren
wir dieses Gas machen wir das mit Kohle
das wäre glaube ich gerade aus
Klimaschutz Gesichtspunkten nicht
vernünftig oder setzen wir noch ein paar
Jahre länger auf die Kernkraft auch auf
heimische Gasförderung ich glaube da
sollten sich auch die Grünen bewegen
gerade wenn in Klimaschutz am Herzen
liegt
Lindner hat heute sein Ziel erreicht die
Partei scheint beseelt für die Ampel
wird es ungemütlicher werden
der heutige sechste Januar ist
traditionell der Auftakt des politischen
Jahres und da gab es noch eine weitere
parteienklausur damit beginnen die
Nachrichten mit dir eins und zwar bei
der CSU deren Landesgruppe im Bundestag
kam zu einer winterklausur im
oberbayerischen Kloster See und zusammen
mit dabei auch der CSU-Vorsitzende
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Söder von ihm
gab es deutliche Kritik an der
Bundesregierung CSU landesgruppenchef
Dobrindt war auf Bundeskanzler Scholz in
der Frage von Panzerlieferungen an die
Ukraine Zögerlichkeit vor und forderte
auch eine Unterstützung mit
leopardlieferungen
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat heute mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten selensky
telefoniert und weitere Unterstützung
zugesagt Regierungssprecher Hebestreit
teilte mit im Jahr 2022 habe die
Bundesregierung die Ukraine bilateral
mit über 12 Milliarden Euro unterstützt
und werde diesen Kurs 2023 fortsetzen
habe sich für die Ankündigung bedankt
der Ukraine eine Patriot
flugabwehrraketenbatterie sowie
Schützenpanzer vom Typ Marder zur
Verfügung zu stellen
in den USA liefern sich die Republikaner
innerhalb ihrer Fraktion weiter einen
Machtkampf das Repräsentantenhaus hat
die Wahl zum Vorsitz daher erneut
vertagt Kevin McCarthy war es nach drei
Tagen und 13 Wahlgängen nicht gelungen
die nötigen Stimmen auf sich zu vereinen
trotz einiger Fortschritte durch
Zugeständnisse an seine Gegner
gab es zuletzt nur 1859
im Nordwesten Mexikos haben sich
mutmaßliche Bandenmitglieder und
Sicherheitskräfte heftige Kämpfe
geliefert laut Behörden starben bei
Schießereien mindestens 29 Menschen
bewaffnete griffen auch einen Flughafen
an Auslöser für die Krawalle war die
Festnahme eines Sohns des Drogenbosses
El Chapo er hatte nach der Inhaftierung
seines Vaters einen Teil von dessen
Kartell übernommen
durch den Klimawandel wird selbst im
günstigsten Fall rund die Hälfte der
weltweiten Gletscher bis zum Ende des
Jahrhunderts verschwinden das geht aus
einer im Fachjournal science
veröffentlichten Studie hervor selbst
eine Begrenzung der Erderwärmung auf 1,5
Grad könnte die Gletscherschmelze nicht
verhindern die Autoren verweisen aber
darauf dass sofortige
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen den Prozess
verlangsamen könnten
heute ist Heiligabend in Russland denn
die russische orthodoxe Kirche richtet
sich nach dem julianischen Kalender
Wladimir Putin der sich immer wieder als
gläubiger Christ inszeniert hat deshalb
eine 36-stündige weihnachtswaffenruhe
verkündet pure Heuchelei heißt es dazu
aus der Ukraine auch für viele Menschen
dort beginnt heute traditionell das
Weihnachtsfest doch immer mehr
ukrainische Christen fühlen sich
inzwischen unwohl mit dem Januar Termin
aus dem russischen Kirchenjahr und
Feststimmung herrscht eh keine Tim
Kröger aus Kiel
noch fällt es igerisch Kapa und Oxana
Gardasee schwer von ihrer Tradition zu
lassen sie sind orthodoxe Christen und
feiern heute und morgen wie auch in all
den Jahren zuvor das Weihnachtsfest die
traditionellen Speisen dürfen dabei
nicht fehlen in Zukunft aber vielleicht
schon beim nächsten Mal können Sie sich
auch den 25 Dezember vorstellen um sich
von Russland abzugrenzen der Krieg hat
vieles verändert
ich habe früher in Russland gearbeitet
aber jetzt ist mein Verhältnis zu
Russland sehr schlecht denn in jeder
Familie musste jemand flüchten oder
getötet oder verletzt
noch einmal gehen Igor und Oxana mit
ihren Kindern an diesem 6 januar in die
Messe vor allem viele junge Menschen
aber wie ihre Tochter Anna wenden sich
von russisch geprägten Traditionen ab
wir wollen mehr mit Europa verbunden
sein aber in unseren Herzen natürlich
Ukrainer bleiben okay
es ist ein Konflikt der auch die beiden
wichtigsten orthodoxen Kirchen in der
Ukraine erreicht hat sie sind gespalten
in einen eher Kiew treuen und einen von
Kritikern als Moskau nah bezeichneten
Teil diese sogenannte
ukrainisch-orthodoxe Kirche gerät
zunehmend unter Druck der Geheimdienst
durchsuchte erst kürzlich Kirchen und
Klöster Priester wurden verhaftet ein
Verbot wird diskutiert
viele Repräsentanten dieser Kirche die
in Kontakt mit der Kirche in Russland
ist versuchen sogenannte russische
narrative in der Ukraine zu verbreiten
und unterstützen die russische
aggressions
die ukrainische orthodoxe Kirche habe
sich nach Kriegsbeginn nicht ausreichend
deutlich von Russland distanziert was
diese zurückweist
unsere Kirche ist absolut loyal dem
Staat gegenüber und seit dem ersten Tag
verteidigen wir unser Land
aber egal in welcher Kirche und wann die
Menschen in der Ukraine Weihnachten
feiern richtige Stimmung kommt
angesichts des Krieges ohnehin nicht auf
es ist sehr schwer unser Land erleidet
so viele Verluste so viele gefallene
Gefangene und verwundete dieser Feiertag
ist völlig anders als in Friedenszeiten
und so wünschen sie sich genau das
Frieden so schnell wie möglich
Tim Krüger guten Abend nach Kiel wie
brüchig ist die Waffenruhe und was
halten die Menschen in der Ukraine davon
also es war schon ganz schön absurd das
ausgerechnet kurz nachdem diese
einseitige Waffenruhe hier begonnen hat
in der gesamten Ukraine Luftalarm
ausgerufen wurde den wir auch hier in
Kiel wahrgenommen haben es ging dabei
ganz offenbar um Flugzeuge die über
Belarus aufgestiegen sind aber es kam
dann wohl doch nicht zu einem Angriff
wir haben auch weitere Berichte bekommen
von der Front im Süden und im Osten
entlang der Kampfzone das ist dort zu
gegenseitig einen Angriffen gekommen ist
das sind aber Berichte die wir von hier
aus nicht verifizieren können wenn man
mit dem Menschen hier spricht dann
halten viele natürlich gar nichts von
dieser wappenruhe wir halten das nicht
für eine Geste des guten Willens ganz im
Gegenteil sie sehen es eher wie die
ukrainische Regierung nämlich dass es
Russland nur darum geht Zeit zu gewinnen
um mehr Militärgerät an die Front zu
bringen mehr Truppen an die Front zu
bringen um dann womöglich nach dieser
Waffenruhe umso harter zuschlagen zu
können die Position hier ist bei den
meisten völlig klar es überhaupt erst
über eine Waffenruhe verhandelt werden
wenn wirklich der letzte russische
Soldat das besetzte Gebiet in der
Ukraine verlassen hat danke Tim nach
Kiew und bei uns geht es weiter mit
Heinz und Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft
und da gibt es für die Industrie in
Deutschland einen Dämpfer beim
Auftragseingang im November zu vermelden
der viel deutlicher aus als erwartet
Valerie Haller noch ist der Bestand dann
Aufträgen hoch aber da kam nun weniger
neue rein wie sind die Reaktionen aus
der Wirtschaft also tatsächlich war ja
eine Delle erwartet worden aber dass sie
so groß ausfallen würde das war dann
doch eine Überraschung vor allem aus dem
Ausland sind die Bestellungen
zurückgegangen das ist keine Katastrophe
noch nicht weil die Industrie ja
tatsächlich auf einem dicken
Auftragspolster sitzt die noch
abgearbeitet werden müssen wegen des
Materialmangels in den vergangenen zwei
Jahren ist nämlich so einiges liegen
geblieben insgesamt fehlen die
Bestellungen im November um über 5% im
Vergleich zum Vormonat vor allem
Großaufträge aus der Eurozone brachen
einem über zehn Prozent noch arbeitet
die Industrie also alte Aufträge ab der
große Einbruch könnte Ende des Jahres
kommen dann möglicherweise umso
deutlicher das sind nun mal schwierige
Zeiten für die Industrie selten hatte
sie mit so vielen Unwägbarkeiten und
Belastungen gleichzeitig zu kämpfen sie
leidet unter steigenden Zinsen
Rezessionsgefahr hohen Energiekosten und
geopolitischer Unsicherheit wie dem
Krieg in der Ukraine gerade bei großen
Investitionsgütern ist die deutsche
Industrie traditionell stark aufgestellt
doch genau die werden in Krisenzeiten
kaum nachgefragt weil Unternehmen
größere Ausgaben scheuen einen
Lichtblick jedoch gibt es die Industrie
kämpft nicht mehr so sehr mit
Materialmangel und das könnte ihr im
Laufe des Jahres Rückenwind geben
vielen Dank
Daniel Barenboim tritt als
Generalmusikdirektor der Berliner
Staatsoper Unter den Linden zurück er
legt das Amt zum Ende des Monats nieder
der 80-Jährige begründete den Rücktritt
mit seiner schweren Erkrankung zum
Jahreswechsel hatte der argentinische
israelische Musiker noch seine Rückkehr
auf die Bühne gefeiert barenbäumen
kündigte an auch weiterhin als Dirigent
tätig sein zu wollen
die Vierschanzentournee ist heute mit
dem Springen in Bischofshofen zu Ende
gegangen Tages-
auch beim letzten Springen ist der
Norweger eine Klasse für sich mit 139
und 143einhalb Metern distanziert er die
Konkurrenz ein weiteres Mal drei Siege
ein zweiter Platz nur ganz knapp
verpasste den vierten grenzlern der
Tournee Geschichte in Bischofshofen
landet kein Deutscher Springer in den
Top Ten bester erneut der Junge Philipp
Reimund als Zwölfter
zu mir gesagt ich habe nicht geglaubt
insgesamt ist diese 71 Ausgabe aber
trotzdem eine enttäuschende aus
deutscher Sicht denn auch in der
Gesamtwertung liegt am Ende kein
DSV-Adler unter den besten Zehn
er wird erster norwegischer Tournee
Sieger seit 16 Jahren vor dem Polen
kopatzki und dem Slowenen schick
eigentlich müsste ich das jetzt singen
wieso weshalb warum wer nicht fragt
bleibt dumm klar es geht um die
Sesamstraße die amerikanische
Kindersendung wird 50 genauer sie wurde
vor 50 Jahren zum ersten Mal in
Deutschland ausgestrahlt und zunächst
gab es riesen Ärger um Ernie und Bert
das Krümelmonster und Frosch Kermit
Pädagogen und Eltern hatten Sorge vor
der Amerikanisierung ihrer Kinder vor
anarchischen Puppen und der
Verherrlichung des Lebens in einer
Mülltonne in New York aus heutiger Sicht
war die Sesamstraße pädagogisch ziemlich
wertvolles Kinderfernsehen Christian von
Rechenberg über das wer wie was
ein Telefon
eine freche Puppe wirklich eine ganz
freche Puppe die Sachen sagt die ein
Kind niemals sagen darf was heißt das im
Fernsehen
Publikum und das ist aber was Kinder
merken wenn sie ernst genommen werden
[Musik]
das war natürlich für viele Eltern und
Erwachsene natürlich etwas was man
überhaupt nicht verstehen konnte denn es
passt ja nicht und das Erziehungskonzept
was man in den 50er 60er Jahre in
Deutschland gehasst hat
kein Wunder bei solchen Typen in der
Sesamstraße gab es davon reichlich heute
hätte ich Kuchen da Kuchen da kuchenbach
[Musik]
mit dir
ja es quietschte in den Köpfen manch
konservative die 68er aber hatten nur
auf dieses Konzept aus Amerika gewartet
antiautoritärer Ansatz Ansprache auf
Augenhöhe und überhaupt die Sache mit
den Puppen die futtern Buchstaben werden
von ihnen verdroschen stellen Fragen und
die Welt auf dem Kopf
Identifikationsfiguren zum dran
Abarbeiten der wahnsinn hat methode
es braucht Figuren die sich entwickeln
können die Fehler machen können die
eckig sein können so wie das Leben
einfach ist so wie Menschen sind und so
wie es auch Kinder kennen Kekse das ist
Raum und Fläche für die Kinder zu gucken
auszuloten vor allen Dingen wie kriegen
die Figuren es dann auch wieder hin
nicht so viele Kekse zu essen denn
Streit nicht eskalieren zu lassen
wir sind hier im Studio Sesamstraße das
ist Samson und das ist Tiffy kurz nach
dem Start in Deutschland bekam die
Sesamstraße ihr eigenes Studio weniger
rustikal wie das US-Vorbild und doch
progressiv inklusive des typisch
teutonischen Spießers doch Länder wie
Bayern ließen die Puppen trotzdem lange
nicht auf Sendung
so laut gehen das ist wie es mit allem
ist alles was neu ist und was innovativ
ist das wird immer erst mal kritisch
beäugt und erstmal per sie erstmal
abgelehnt
Geburtswehen die Straße der Rebellen ist
längst aufgenommen ins wohlbehütete
deutsche bildungsdenken auch mit Themen
die gar nicht so lustig sind Armut
Alkoholismus AIDS alles kann man Kindern
erklären es ist wichtig den Kindern Mut
zu machen nachzufragen nicht alles sich
gefallen zu lassen nach warum Fragen zu
stellen was hat diese erst am Straße mit
ihren Figuren und mit ihren Themen denke
ich sehr sehr gut gemacht also lassen
wir die Puppen weiter tanzen und
Wünschen der pelzigen Rasselbande alles
Gute danke für die vielen Ohrwürmer und
die besten Kumpels unserer Kindheit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Kekse Kult seit 50 Jahren uns gibt es
morgen schon wieder und unser heute
schon mal Update um nur 40 einen guten
Abend ihnen und tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eigentlich müsste
es Anfang Januar viel kälter sein ist es
aber nicht denn immer wieder kommt Tiefs
heran und lenken Warmluft nach
Deutschland ja aus dem Südwesten kommt
diese Warmluft und so steigen die
Temperaturen morgen wieder bis auf 14
Grad zumindest beim Regen gibt es eine
kurze Pause es wird morgen trocken
bleiben im Süden wird es Nebel geben in
der Nähe von Gewässern ansonsten zieht
im Norden etwas Regen durch aber das ist
nicht viel es wird dann auch dort bald
trocken werden Temperaturen sinken auf
-3 Grad am Alpenrand und zehn Grad ganz
im Westen Deutschlands
morgen dann von Anfang an viel
Sonnenschein im Süden dort wo der Nebel
noch da ist es länger trüb etwa bis
mittags rum dann löst er sich teilweise
auf im Nordosten ebenfalls dichte
Bewölkung ja und insgesamt aber
trockenes Wetter die Temperaturen dazu
erreichen höchste Werte von 4 Grad im
Dauernebel im Süden 13 Grad im Westen
Deutschlands und 14 Grad am Oberrhein
häufig allerdings immer noch
Temperaturen im zweistelligen Bereich
die nächsten Tage es kommt wieder neuer
Regen auf am Sonntag der dehnt sich dann
der Nacht auf Montag weiter nach
Nordosten aus ja aber die nächsten Tage
werden dann etwas kühler sein allerdings
vom Winter weiterhin keine Spur damit
ein schöner Abend